[Musique]
les orientations budgétaires 2024
poursuivent les actions initiées en 2023
et renforce les démarches de proximité
le halé vert pour répondre aux attentes
de tous les réignonnaés sur tout le
territoire l'axe majeur de cette
ambition est la proximité renforcée la
démarche du halé vert qui amène les
dispositifs au plus près des territoires
trois caravanes d'accès au droit et à
l'information se déplace sur chacune des
microrégions en 2024 des villages de
caravanes multiartenariat verront le
jour des Dallons de quartier
complèteront ce dispositif de l'action
sociale l'amélioration de l'accueil
inconditionnel de proximité se
concrétise avec les travaux dans les
maisons départemental et la formation
des équipes en charge de
l'accompagnement des
publics l'accompagnement à la
parentalité se construit autour des
weekends parentalités de la M sociale et
avec la mise en œuvre du panjou le plan
départemental des préventions des
violences intrafamiliales est lancé avec
un axe fort la protection des enfants la
capacité d'accueil en centre sera
également renforcée et les parcours de
prise en charge
sécurisé accompagner le maintien à
domicile et lutter contre l'habitat
insalubre reste un engagement fort de la
collectivité pour financer
l'amélioration des 3000 logements
objectif 2024 le département
s'appuierera sur une convention à passer
avec l'État pour mobiliser des fonds de
laalbu le département élabore un plan
d'action afin de renforcer les services
d'aide à domicile un plan
d'accompagnement des accueillants
familiaux sera déployé afin de
professionnaliser les acteurs et
apporter de l'attractivité au métier la
collectivité avec ses partenaires
conforte le dispositif du transfert
sanitaire et du rapatriment des
dépouilles
mortuaires le plan départemental de
2023- 2024 en faveur de la réussite des
jeunes poursuit son déploiement
accompagner et orienter les jeunes dans
la réussite de leur parcours scolaire au
travers du schéma directeur des
équipements numériques et du schéma
général de la restauration scolaire la
collectivité souhaite créer des espaces
de parole pour les jeunes afin de
prendre en compte leurs attentes et
ajuster les actions soutenues un
institut d'apprentissage de la vie
citoyenne accompagnera la jeunesse dans
la voie de la
[Musique]
citoyenneté
la collectivité veut conforter son
accompagnement auprès des acteurs du
sport et de la culture l'histoire et le
patrimoine de la réunion seront
valorisés et accessible à tous au sein
des équipements culturels le musée de
villel est réhabilité en musée de
l'habitation et de l'esclavage la
promotion du sport est active auprès des
jeunes et des sportifs de haut niveau la
Réunion accueillera la flamme olympique
le 12 juin 2024 un événement populaire
partagé autour des valeurs du
[Musique]
sport
en tant qu'autorité de gestion des fonds
fadir pour la période
2023-2027 la collectivité poursuit sa
politique de développement agricole
conformément au plan agripays 2030
tenant compte des objectifs ambieux en
matière de souveraineté alimentaire et
de valorisation de nos produits soutenir
la filière bio encourager les circuits
courts et redynamiser les acteurs pour
créer une dynamique agricole coordonné
avec la marque 100 % la Réunion le
transfert de l'eau et l'extension des
périmètres irrigués poursuivre avec le
projet Meren Prodeo et pis
[Musique]
Sud l'objectif est de contribuer à un
aménagement harmonieux du territoire et
des grands sites naturels le département
poursuit les opérations d'aménagement du
git du volcan du git du python des
neiges et de béouv l'entretien des
routes départementales la suppression
des radiers et les travaux de
réhabilitation et de reconstruction des
collèges se poursuivent avec le PST2 la
collectivité soutient la création
d'équipements de proximité dans les
communes le programme LEADER
2023-2027 accompagne le développement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
des les premiers états généraux de la
forêt et la lutte contre les espèces
invasives sont des priorités pour la
préservation de notre biodiversité pour
atténuer les effets du changement
climatique la collectivité poursuit son
engagement et lance de nouvelles
expérimentations avec le déploiement du
plan 1 million d'arbres le développement
de la production d'électricité d'origine
photovoltaque
et la valorisation des déchets
alimentaires dans les
collèges la coopération régionale uvre
au renforcement des liens dans la zone
Océan Indien en favorisant la mobilité
internationale des apprentis et en
valorisant l'expertise réonnaise à
l'échelle régionale la collectivité
accompagne ainsi le développement de
projets dans les pays de la
[Musique]
zone la modernisation de l'action
publique au sein des services de la
collectivité les procédures pour les
usagers avec d'abord la mise en œuvre du
plan de transformation numérique et de
sa gouvernance et des expérimentations
menées avec la dématérialisation du
paiement des aides départementales les
agents et les managers du département
suivent également un plan de formation
basé sur le développement des
compétences et des conditions de travail
le soutien au porteur de projet se
poursuit avec la 2e édition du budget
d'initiative citoyenne 80 projets
financés pour un montant de 1 million
d'euros en
2024 en améliorant ses méthodes de
travail en interne et en incluant
davantage les réunionnés dans ses
politiques publiques et ses décisions la
collectivité répond à ses orientation
adapter et déployer ces dispositifs au
plus près des
réunionnés